the Border agents are begging DHS
secretary mayork is to show up and do
something but instead he just attended a
fancy dinner party with MSNBC host and
honchos celebrating jinsaki's new show
Joe Concha joins us now Joe how bad does
it look that my orcas was hobnobbing
with MSNBC literally just moments after
his border patrol Chief mind you
testified on Capitol Hill and by on
Capitol Hill I mean at the border on
Capitol Hill that the federal government
does not have operational control of the
Border
it looks Elite it looks out of touch it
looks apathetic towards what is
absolutely a crisis to many Democrats
now saying at least those who have law
making abilities in Arizona and Texans
are saying is absolutely a catastrophe
and a crisis and I guess Todd what we
got was a preview of what gen saki's new
show is going to look like and if she
right if she were to have uh secretary
mayorkas on her show why do we all get
the feeling that he won't be asked even
remotely one fair or tough question
regarding his F minus failure at the U.S
Southern border MSNBC simply does not
care by the way how this looks this was
a celebration dinner for Jen saki's new
show in public at a restaurant with
plenty of photos being taken and from
what I've seen regarding Miss sake so
far during her appearances on the
network she is utterly uninteresting and
inauthentic you take Peter Ducey or
Jackie Heinrich out of her life when she
doesn't have a foil to spar against
instead put her in an echo chamber
you'll see how low those ratings are
when they come out next week save the
tape Ashley you know
obviously it looks bad to America but
Vince you could uh
yesterday and he said that 17 of the
agents have committed suicide it's that
bad to where they're taking their own
life and for them to see him going to
these Posh parties what a slap in the
face to those agents who are protecting
our border when they just want him to
come down there and do something
anything Joe but we do have to get to
this second gentleman Doug imhoff making
some pretty shocking comments about
parents protesting woke ideology in
schools listen
I met one woman who was saved in the
Holocaust in Germany settled in Ukraine
and is now a refugee again this stuff is
so important this hate is interconnected
you see it in the discourse in the
country right now you see it in the in
the divide that we have and that just
going to the school meeting you see that
that heat that is out there
your reaction to what you just heard
wow at last check I think that uh Doug
amoff and Kamala Harris don't have kids
and that that's fine to each their own
but I have a feeling if the second
gentleman did have children as I do as
so many parents out there watching right
now do uh and he learned that his first
grader was being taught about gender
identification sexual orientation and a
school that his taxpayer money was going
towards he may show up at the school
board meeting and demand transparency as
well and this is why by the way we have
a governor Junkin in Virginia which was
quite the blue State until he came along
and ran on the education issue it's one
of the reasons why we have a Ron
DeSantis just being reelected by 20
points in Florida it was based on their
simple stance and it's logical I don't
even think it's a conservative stance I
think it's a common sense one that
parents have a right to know what their
children are being taught plain and
simple and dug him off simply does not
get that while he's talking about how
horrible divide is in this country and
then says the exact divisive things that
help bring divide in this country Todd
yeah they don't have kids together he's
got I believe a child from a previous
marriage but it's older so you know your
situation where you're not going through
the same shenanigans that children in
this day and age are going through I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis